Speaker 1: I want to go through something that's
just it's so crass and it's so emblematic,
I guess I would say, of the kind of vapid and
coarse nature of the modern Republican Party
radical. If you say to me, David, sir were the
three sort of most cartoonish clowns in the House
of Representatives right now, I would say, Well,
it's Marjorie Taylor Greene, it's Madison Cawthorn
and it's Lauren Boebert. And then after that,
there's a lot of candidates. You know, it could
be Matt Gates, Louie Gohmert very, very long
list, but certainly in the top three as I hit
my microphone here and almost almost damage it.
I'm Lauren Boebert would certainly be in the top
three. Lauren Boebert has been given the hottest
woman in Congress award by one of these right
wing channels, and the award misspelled her name
and included a gift card to red to Red Lobster,
to the seafood chain Red Lobster. If you were
to satirize the modern Republican Party on a
show like Saturday Night Live, you would create
a hottest woman in Congress award, misspelled the
recipient's name and include a gift card to like
Arby's or Red Lobster or something like that is
exactly what you would do. Let's let's take a look
at this. If you look at her holding the award,
you see that her name had been spelled Lauren
Boebert within a BRT and then sort of corrected.
Honestly, it looks like a Sharpie to be Lauren
Boebert with an E or bobble as Congressman Ro
Khanna referred to her. And there's a gift card
in there, and that gift card is to Red Lobster,
and it's in the amount of $27 and 43 cents,
which I guess the point there is you as a
member of Congress, you you violate some
ethics laws if you accept a gift worth
more than $50. So I guess that's how they
came up with twenty seven point forty three
cents. Here is her being told by Jesse Kelly,
who knows who these people are about the award.
Speaker 3: Joining me now, the first winner of the
Jesse Kelly's show Hottest Woman in Congress List
Congresswoman from Colorado Lauren
Boebert. Congresswoman, first and foremost,
before we get to all the news of the day,
I want to congratulate you on such a high
achievement and hope you got ours. I see you did
get our certificate. And I want to make sure you
also got the gift card we sent along with it.
Speaker 4: I got it like a bad Jesse held that
Jesse. I do think that twenty seven forty three is
under the gift limit, but if we check with ethics
and it's over, this is coming right back to you.
Speaker 3: Yes, ma'am. I understand that we are
going to do the best we can to up that to 30 next
year, depending on how the show does, but moving
forward. The second hottest woman in Congress, she
was the runner up this year. AOC went on Twitter
and whined once again like she always. Yeah.
Speaker 1: You know, Trump's flushing documents
down the toilet. Boebert is getting misspelled.
Hottest Woman in Congress Award. If this is a
simulation, someone has a very interesting sense
of humor, and I think the important thing here is
I keep going back. You know, we talk about how do
we engage with these people? How do you how do you
talk sense into folks who believe the things that
people like Lauren Boebert and Marjorie Taylor
Greene and others say? Is it just a matter of
having a few conversations with them or whatever?
I never want to say that people, generally
speaking, are too far gone. But you have to
understand that there is sort of like a culture
of ignorance and anti-intellectual ism and a
sort of pride in lacking any sophistication
or depth in one's thinking. And, you know,
Lauren Boebert getting the hottest woman award
and it's been misspelled. It's not the be all
end all of reminding us about that reality
right now among this right wing American
political movement and the fact that this is how
unsophisticated and anti-intellectual they are.
But it's just a reminder that this movement is
so pervasive and I'm reminded of this, you know,
whenever I go to a conservative state and all of
a sudden, I'm in the middle of you. Some fair or
whatever the case may be, I'm reminded there's
nobody who could come here and just talk sense
into these people in any real way. And that's
what gets us to. We just have to get voter
turnout up. We have to just overwhelm them with
numbers because most of them are not going to be
convinced. We've got to fix education, so we
prevent people from becoming this uninformed
in the first place. It is a colossal task that
we are faced with in this country, and this is
just a little microcosm of that. That really
epitomizes how you can't distinguish between
how these right wingers would be satirized
on sit and comedy programs and what they
actually are. There's essentially no daylight
between those who did those two things anymore